he shall be the greatest who can be the
most solitary the most concealed the
most divergent the man beyond good and
evil the master of his virtues and of
superabundance of will precisely this
shall be called greatness as diversified
as can be entire example has come before
and to ask her once more the question
is greatness possible nowadays beyond
good and evil was first published in
1886 and it is considered the further
elaboration of the ideas nietzsche
introduced in the spoke zarathustra it
is clear from the title of the book that
nietzsche's main goal is to unleash a
critique on the preconceived notions of
good and evil as this were defined
mainly by philosophers and religion
beyond good and evil essentially means
that reality and people cannot be seen
under a binary prism of morality but
each attempt to define morality needs to
be nuanced and thorough the subtitle of
the book is a prelude to a philosophy of
the future he clearly understands that
the world is changing and he wants to
use this realization as a motivation to
attack everything that is holding us
back from embracing change and evolution
in the book nietzsche adopts his usual
critical and polemical approach he
starts the prologue of the book with a
very intriguing statement supposing that
truth is a woman what then is there not
ground for suspecting that all
philosophers in so far as they have been
dogmatists have failed to understand
women that the terrible seriousness and
clumsy persistence with which they have
usually paid their addresses to truth
have been unskilled and unseemly methods
for winning a woman during nietzsche's
time dogmatic truths were the norm
psychology and other sciences were still
at an embryonic stage and people relied
on abstract belief systems to interpret
truth and reality he believes that this
approach is clumsy and wrong and it
can't help philosophers win the truth
which he considers to be a woman ergo
difficult to understand after his
polemic towards philosophers he goes on
addressing a plethora of topics like the
notion of the free spirit the natural
history of morals and analysis of people
and countries of his time as well as his
examination of the essence of nobility
it is important to note that nietzsche
considered a lot of his views as an
experiment in abstract reasoning he is
someone whose methodology is deeply
entangled in what could be called
what-if scenarios as it is stated in the
introduction of the cambridge edition of
the book we find embedded in nietzsche's
basic view of himself the recommendation
not that we read his texts as aiming at
objectively valid judgments adjustments
that are true irrespective of the
cultural and psychological context in
which they are made but that we think of
them as narratives that he invites us to
listen to without really obliging us to
believe in them reading nietzsche
requires an open mind we expect a lot
from philosophers but we also need to
see nietzsche's works as a fusion of
philosophy poetry and masterfully
articulated abstract reasoning he was a
pioneer of thought and regardless of the
errors spotted in some of his thinking
motifs he still revolutionized the way
we think and we should all be grateful
for this
it is the business of the very few to be
independent it is the privilege of the
strong and whoever attempts it even with
the best right but without being obliged
to do so proves that he is probably not
only strong but also daring beyond
measure he enters into a labyrinth he
multiplies a thousand-fold the dangers
which life in itself already brings with
it not the list of which says that not
one can see how and where he loses his
way becomes isolated and his torn
piecemeal by some minotaur of conscience
supposing such a one comes to grief it
is so far from the comprehension of men
that they neither feel it nor sympathize
with it and he cannot any longer go back
he cannot even go back again to the
sympathy of men
owning oneself is not an easy task
nietzsche looks at the world around him
and sees mainly people who prefer to be
dependent rather than independent this
annoyed him a lot and to the degree that
he adopted more or less an elitist
stance towards others and this becomes
more apparent in his idea about slave
and master morality as this will be
discussed in a bit nietzsche believed
that it's in our passions where we find
ourselves this belief constituted one of
his main attempts to use philosophy as
an instrument to understand and engage
with the human psyche throughout the
enlightenment reason was the predominant
virtue essentially most philosophers
espoused the view that through reason a
person becomes enlightened nietzsche
however opposed this idea as quite
conservative he believed that reason the
way it was portrayed during his time was
equated with conservatism and
suppression of our nature he does not
want us to suppress our instincts our
passions our emotions but to confront
them and embrace them that is how we
understand ourselves better that is how
we own ourselves
without a deep understanding of the
nature of our inner world we are just
constantly exposed to a fake reality and
become victims to the twists and turns
of life we must constantly test
ourselves as he writes one must subject
oneself to one's own tests that one is
destined for independence and command
and do so at the right time one must not
avoid one's tests although they
constitute perhaps the most dangerous
game one can play and are in the end
tests made only before ourselves and
before no other judge
how could anything originate out of its
opposite for example truth out of error
or the will to truth out of the will to
deception or the generous deed out of
selfishness in spite of all the value
which may be longer to the true the
positive and the unselfish it might be
possible that a higher and more
fundamental value for life generally
should be assigned to pretense to the
will to delusion to selfishness and
cupidity it might even be possible that
what constitutes the value of those good
and respected things consists precisely
in their being insidiously related noted
and crocheted to this evil and
apparently opposed things perhaps even
in being essentially identical with them
perhaps but who wishes to concern
himself with such dangerous perhapses
reading nietzsche can be frustrating at
times as a person who is strongly
defending his positions one would
imagine that he is an evangelist of
truth but why is he so adamantly
promulgating the opposite of that in the
previous passage in another passage he
writes the strength of a person's spirit
would then be measured by how much truth
he could tolerate or more precisely to
what extent he needs to have it diluted
disguised sweetened muted falsified the
contradiction is quite evident or is it
i guess that every great thinker needs
to battle with this kind of
contradictions truth can be difficult to
define at times truth can be nuanced it
can be multifaceted it can be
complicated our willingness to pursue it
constitutes a very onerous endeavor and
our ability to tolerate truth showcases
the strength of our character granted
that we want the truth why not rather
untruth and uncertainty even ignorance
the problem of the value of truth
presented itself before us or was it we
who presented ourselves before the
problem the idea of questioning almost
everything is emblematic of nietzsche's
writing style through this process he
recognizes that one becomes smarter and
cultivates a more holistic understanding
of the world more specifically he likes
to go against the dogmatic nature of
philosophical prejudices so he urges us
to question our assumptions and our
dogmatic beliefs especially when we
philosophize as i said before nietzsche
wrote this book during a time when
psychology and science were at an
embryonic stage he was sensing that we
will be in a position very soon to
understand the world around us better so
it is time to destroy the old world and
lay the groundwork for the new one
in a tour through the many finer and
coarser moralities which have hitherto
prevailed or still prevail on the earth
i found certain traits recurring
regularly together and connected with
one another until finally two primary
types revealed themselves to me and the
radical distinction was brought to light
there is master morality and slave
morality nietzsche touches upon the
concept of master versus slave morality
in beyond good and evil
and expands on it in the genealogy of
morality before i attempt an analysis of
the concept i want to point out that i'm
not in favor of the use of the words
master and slave here nietzsche believes
in self-responsibility so he considers
hierarchies a natural byproduct of our
nature the ones who are strong and
responsible will rise to the top of the
hierarchy and the ones who aren't will
stay at the bottom for me such
distinctions are just by-products of our
social mythology i am against
hierarchies and against anything that
creates inequality and polarization
within our social systems regardless
nietzsche tries to make a point here the
point is that a person who adheres to a
master morality is a person with a
heroic attitude he alludes to the
ancient greek heroes as archetypes of
this kind of morality master morality is
the morality of the strong willed its
essence is to focus on everything that
is noble qualities that are often valued
in master morality are open-mindedness
courage truthfulness trustworthiness and
inaccurate sense of self-worth on the
other hand slave morality is the
morality of the weak-minded as it is
eloquently stated in wikipedia slave
morality does not aim at exerting one's
will by strength but by careful
subversion nietzsche believes that
people who adhere to slave morality seek
equality just because they don't want to
work on themselves and instead of trying
to become masters they prefer to bring
everyone to their own level again i
believe that this is a critique to
everything that is weak similar to
seneca's critique when he wrote that all
cruelty springs from weakness the slave
and master morality can be competing
forces within one's psyche as he writes
i would at once add however that in all
higher and mixed civilizations there are
also attempts at the reconciliation of
the two moralities but one still finds
off an error the confusion and mutual
misunderstanding of them indeed
sometimes their close juxtaposition even
in the same man within one soul
nietzsche didn't propose the master
slave morality dichotomy as a panacea to
our moral conundrums he believed that a
constant re-evaluation of our moral
landscape could give us a better
understanding of our inner world as i
said before these are not the most ideal
terms to use when covering such
sensitive topics but nietzsche always
wanted to make noise and would use
controversial terms in order to be heard
in any case while aiming towards a
philosophy of the future one must always
have in mind that equality cannot exist
without self-responsibility
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now
you